Om vi säljer samma saker till samma pris, och ena levererar på tre dagar och den andra på tre timmar, så kommer man välja den som är snabbare.
Det är en stor förändring i sektorn som sker.
Det börjar hända i Europa och det kommer snart vara normalt med samma eller nästa dagsleveranser även i Sverige.
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har rendesbra ord.
Ni har inga sura kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig, och det finns inga tulliga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger det.
Jag håller med, men vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Dino Todorovic till podden Make Sweden Stronger och jag kan ju alltid känna en viss ångest när jag träffar människor som är bättre än mig, för då känner jag att jag behöver överprestera eller sånt där.
Du har varit med på listan Forbes 30 under 30, och när jag var under 30 så pillade jag fortfarande naveludd.
Hur var det att vara ambitiös som ung?
Oj, det är inget jag har reflekterat över.
Jag vet inte, det har nog kommit naturligt.
Jag har nog alltid jobbat mycket, pluggat mycket, tror det kommer från mina föräldrar, framförallt min pappa.
Jobbade nästan dig när jag trodde det skulle jag säga under hela min uppväxt.
Så, inget jag har reflekterat över.
Men är du ett sånt där jobbigt A-barn som är du bra på allting du gör, eller valde du de här tre grejerna jag är bra på så jag kör på det och skiter i resten?
Nej jag har absolut inte varit bra på allt, men jag vann buchast i skolan när jag fick få betyg.
När man kommer från en utläsningssamilj, det tenderar att bli så att skolan är väldigt viktig, och så var det i mitt fall.
Det var mycket push att studera och det gjorde jag, gjorde bra ifrån mig.
Men det var väl det som ett område.
Var rätt duktig i sporten också, men långt ifrån duktig på allt.
Jag gillar också, jag bara gissar att din skala är annorlunda här än min egen skala.
När jag intervjuade han Benjamin på Nine Pines, som har varit lite uppe i media, så sa han att att mer att spela gitarr, det är liksom lite rebelliskt.
För han spelade inte piano liksom, som var mer Asian style, som han sade då, och då, jag bara älskar att hans skala på rebellisk är spela gitarr, om det liksom inte, det är inte vad jag lägger som en rebellisk ungdom.
Vad är du riktigt kass på?
Kan du delga oss här så att vi får slatna av lite i vår jämförelsehets?
Nej men vi klipper det här.
Ja, sätta riktigt vad jag är riktigt kass på.
Kan du inte berätta om din bakgrund här lite som företagande?
Hur drog det igång?
Vad var första inkörsporten och vad var första viktiga bolaget, eller riktiga som inte var, jag sålde ett te vid gatan eller samlade burkar.
Jag tror det började med att jag sommarjobbade i mina föräldrars restaurang.
De själva drev då eget och det blev ganska naturligt för mig att tänka att man kan starta nåt eget och att det kanske är det jag borde göra när jag blir äldre.
Så jag kom in på det, sen så kom jag in väldigt mycket på teknik.
Jag var mycket av en teknik nerd när jag var yngre och det ledde till att jag programmerade hemsidan till föräldrarnas restaurang.
Sen så fick alla grannar ha en hemsida.
På något sätt så blev det naturligt att man kunde starta ett eget och tjäna pengar av sig själv utan att få ett jobb eller en anställning.
Så det var väl den vägen och jag studerade, fick jobb på storbolag, tyckte det var ganska tråkigt att sitta där.
Så redan under studierna studerade jag bland ingenjör och där på KTH då så drog jag igång ett första företag.
Det var allt annat än framgångsrikt men det var titta ner i Körsport till att det här är vad jag vill göra.
Jag kände att det var definitivt mycket roligare än att vara anställd på en storbolag.
Och sen så fick jag lite andra olika jobb, blandat på startup och kände efter ett tag att jag vill starta något igen.
Och det för riktiga kan man säga, det var väl när vi startade Vemblas matleveransföretag som drog igång under pandemin.
Det var ju ett litet, jag vet inte om man säger hypat företag, men det hördes och det gick fort.
Kan du berätta lite om den resan bara?
Absolut, vi hade lycklig timing där.
Jag träffade en av medelgrunderna 2018, och vi bestämde oss för att dra igång det här 2019 och såg mycket runt om i världen.
Matleveranser, ganska vanligt i Asien, USA, det borde komma till Sverige förr eller senare.
Och vi bestämde oss för att dra igång 2019, började bygga en test lanserad under sommaren där.
Fick intresse, det började komma in lite order så vi gjorde dem manuellt.
Och så som det funkade var egentligen att du handlade från din närmsta batbutik.
Så vi åkte dit och handlade som att det vore du, vi körde hem då din matkasse, alltså matvaror, på en timme.
Och det fick bra intresse under pilotfasen och vi började då bygga vår egen plattform.
Och den lanserade vi med NAAD 2020 så släppte vi vår app på App Store, där du då som konsument kunde hitta dina matbutiker och börja handla sådär.
Och det var ju bara en-två månader innan pandemin slått till.
Och det var ju en fantastisk timing för helt plötsligt så blev det här kanske det viktigaste och hetaste av allt som kunde finnas i världen.
Hur får jag den här min mat när jag inte kan gå ut och handla?
Så därifrån så exploderade det och under det året så skalade vi upp väldigt fort och då vart det rätt hypat.
När du säger väldigt fort, vad innebär väldigt fort?
Vad var det som skalades upp väldigt fort?
Vi var kanske tre till fem personer som satt i en källare, hade släppt en app som hade tre beställningar i veckan.
Det var ingenting.
Jag minns inte exakta datum men jag minns att vi gick in på Google och gjorde någon sökning och så stod det där som var pandemi.
Så vi bara kolla, det står att det är pandemi.
Vad gör man där då?
Vi gick från tre beställningar i veckan till att få tre beställningar en dag.
Och sen nästa dag var det sex beställningar, sen var det tio, sen var det femton, tjugo.
Och vi gick från att vara tre till fem personer till kanske inklusive alla som körde sånt, så tog det två månader innan vi var 30-40 personer.
Men har du gjort någon sån uppskalningsresa innan så att du var beredd på såhär ska man hantera det här eller blev du bara fucking hell, vad händer nu?
Nej, vi var tagna på sängen.
Hade ingen aning om vi skulle hantera det där.
Så det blev mycket trial and error.
Och vad var det som var svårt?
För det är på något sätt detta folk drömmer om.
Men vad var det som inte var drömmen i det där?
Tekniken funkar okej, men det är alltid strul.
Tekniken funkar okej.
Det är alltid strul och det hände relativt nyligen vi hade lanserat appen.
Så det var en del buggar, så det var en huvudvärk också.
Men det funkar väl någorlunda bra.
Däremot att skala upp något fysiskt är alltid jättesvårt.
Speciellt om man ska göra det fort.
Så vi gjorde väldigt mycket själva i den modellen.
Det var en ganska tung modell för dels byggde vi tekniken för konsumenten att handla, men också för dem som faktiskt utförde leveransen, hela logistikkedjan.
Sen så var vi en e-handlare så vi sålde också online med marknadsföring och allt vad det innebar.
På det så var det last mile, plock, pack, onboarda, egen utrustning, cyklar och sådär.
Det var mycket utrustning som skulle köpas in, mycket personal som skulle lära sig upp.
Det var ganska tufft.
Det var många unga som kanske inte handlade så mycket i matbutik, så du kan tänka dig själv att lära 40-
och 20-åringar och plocka en bra avocado, det är inte helt lätt.
Det var hela tiden den modellen ni körde på, och det blev aldrig att ni samsynkade och bara blev en mellanhand för butiker, utan ni gjorde alltid både utkörning och plock och hela...
Det var mestadels så.
Det var några butiker som hjälpte oss att plocka och packa grejerna så att vi bara körde.
Men under min tid så var det nästan bara så att vi gjorde allt själva.
Sen så lämnade jag där i årsskiftet 2020-2021 och då slog de mig över till en annan modell som var en så kallad darkstore-modell där man istället för att hämta från egna butiker, istället för att hämta från matbutiker, alltså IK och sådant, så hade man då egna små mikrolager som man gjorde till en matbutik.
Men varför lämnade du?
Kan du...
Får du dela det?
Det är väl inget hemligt.
Det var nog flera anledningar.
Det var tre stycken som dels hade lite olika vision, sen hade vi kört ganska hårt här under en period, och jag skötte både teknik och logistikdelen.
Så det var nog lite för mycket jobb.
Håret började trilla av så till slut så började jag ta det lite lugnt.
Logistik och teknik, var det något mer?
Det låter som ett logistik och teknikbolag.
Vad gjorde de andra?
Flansche, nej jag ska inte veta, jag bara menar vad är kvar?
Ja men det var marknadsföring och en massa annat som börjades i år också såklart.
Ja, nej jag fattar det, jag tyckte bara det var kul.
Och vad hände sen?
Fick du en liten paus eller kände du att nej, logistik det vill jag fortsätta med och teknik vill jag fortsätta med.
Så då opererade du existerande bolag.
Ja, nej men både och skulle jag säga.
Jag var ganska mattar efter två år, så jag vilade ett tag men började bli ganska rastlös fort och funderade på vad ska jag göra med livet.
Det var mycket över ett sådant år där jag faktiskt satt och tänkte på vad har jag för mening med livet, vad ska jag göra, vad har jag hållit på med, bara kört på utan nåt riktigt att tänka.
Men landade till slut i att jag tyckte det var väldigt kul att göra det jag gjorde på Vembla och fick med mig många bra lärdomar.
Framförallt inom just den sektorn med e-handel, logistik och de trender som börjar komma.
Jag följde dem ganska noga och såg hur Amazon med Amazon Prime växte, snabba leveranser, märkte hur Vemblas kunder verkligen älskade att få just så här hållbara och snabba leveranser.
Och det slog mig att det här borde komma till all sorts e-handel och inte bara takeaway och matvaror.
Så jag satt och funderade på hur kommer den här branschen och sektorn utvecklas och finns det någonting jag kan göra med den kunskapen jag har fått under de här åren.
Och det blev förövärt till Brisso.
Där jag sen tänkte att det här måste kunna gå att göra för e-handlare och det blir något svårt för e-handlare att göra det själva.
Så det behövs en tredje part som hjälper dem.
Och därför växte idén att kunna ge motsvarande erbjuden som Vembl hade med en timmes leveranser helt hållbara till alla e-handlare.
För det är det ni gör, ni hanterar hela lagersetappen och levererar.
Är det så det funkar?
Ja men precis, vi har inga leveranser, men vi är en så kallad tredje parts logistiker.
Så det innebär att vi hjälper e-handlare med hela deras logistik.
Och så som man oftast tänker på en tredjepartslogistik eller en TREPL som det kallas, det är ju stora centrallager där man skickar över hela världen och det har ju vi också.
När vi hjälper e-handlare typiskt sätt så tar vi över hela deras logistik.
Där man då skickar alla sina varor till vårt centrallager och vi därifrån sedan då hanterar alla order som skickar över hela världen.
Så det är väldigt likt hur andra TREPL gör det.
Det som är skillnaden då är att utöver det centrallagret, där vi hanterar all logistik, så har vi även små mikrohubbar där vi kan erbjuda om en här typ av logistik.
Så vi flyttar en del av sortimentet till hubbar in i storstäderna så att vi därifrån kan anlita cykelbud.
Så vi kör inte själva men genom att vi är så centrala så kan olika typer av cykelbud komma och hämta upp varorna och då är det möjligare en leverans på e-handlarens hemsida inom en timme till samma kväll nästa morgon helt emissionsrytt.
Är det en tjänst som e-handlaren betalar för eller är det ni som ser i er data att de här varorna köps ofta och hade passat till de här hubbarna eller hur avgör vad som är stora centrallager och vad som är små centrala hubbar?
Men det varierar.
Det beror helt på vad man får tippa i e-handlare och stort sortiment man har.
De allra minsta e-handlarna som kanske har fem varor, där kan man ha hela sortimentet i en mikrohubb.
Då är det bjuda allt till express-leverans.
Men typiskt sett så har man lite fler produkter och då får man titta på toppsäljare.
Oftast är det 80-20-regeln och tenderar det till att 5% av produkten står för 50% av försäljningen.
Så vi tittar mycket på data, vad säljs i just det här området.
Men sen är det också så att olika kategorier passar bättre än andra.
Allt som ska konsumeras, tester, presentartiklar och så vidare.
Och för en hel del e-handlare så till exempel kläder har mycket drop.
Så nu ska vi släppa en ny kollektion, då vill vi att man ska kunna få den på en timme eller samma dag, det ska inte ta för lång tid.
Live videoshopping där man vill kunna köra en live video och få leveransen under själva videon eller den här shopping-sessionen.
Så det finns en massa olika scenario, vissa släpper nya varumärken och sådär.
Då väljer man just de produkterna.
Kan ni se det till exempel på, jag bara tänker om jag hade haft ett klädvarumärke, kan ni se det på att vi har mycket returer på den här, så det vill vi gärna ha snabba leveranser på, för då får vi tillbaks till lager i Sallåt snabbt för att slippa den.
Är det så folk använder det, eller är det snarare att de här produkterna säljs inte om det inte är snabba leveranser?
Hur brukar e-handlare resonera?
Grundtanken är egentligen att du får bättre konvertering och säljer mer om du kan erbjuda snabbare leveranser, kort och gott.
Sen varierar det, jag skulle säga att returer har inte varit en så stor del, ofta när du behöver något snabbt så har du bestämt dig för att du vill ha det och du kommer använda det direkt så det blir inte så mycket returer, även om det kan hända.
Men det är sällan av den anledningen det har varit.
Utan det har varit mycket, dels att man kanske vill hajpa en produkt, marknadsföring, kunna säga att man erbjuder en typ av tjänst, eller bara för att det är en typ av produkt som verkligen ökar konverteringen om du levererar snabbt.
Tror du folk på det?
Om jag hade läst på en hemsida och så står det typ, vi levererar inom två timmar, då hade jag ju typ tänkt, fan, det är inte sant.
Nej men det händer ofta att folk är skeptiska och frågar så, är det verkligen på riktigt?
Vi har ju följt upp med många kunder som har valt en typ av tjänst, och många tror ju att det är till och med scam i början.
När vi har alla testat det så kommer de ofta tillbaka.
De här mikrubbarna, hur stora är de?
Och hade jag i teorin kunnat ställa in gymgolv där på 400 kvadrat, och bara säga att jag skiter i att det inte är logiskt, jag vill bara att ni ska leverera plattor nu på Expressleverans.
Finns det gränser?
Ja nej men det finns gränser.
Jag vet inte om gymgolv är det ideala produkten.
Typiskt sett så vill man väl ha en relativt hög värde densitet, relativt sett småprodukter till värdet på produkten.
Det är också så att oftast är det cykelbud som kör direkt, om man ska ha den här absolut snabbaste leveransen, en-två timmar.
Så då har man ju viktgräns på runt 6 kilo och vissa måttbegränsningar.
Sen kan du ju ha lite större grejer om det inte blir dem just Express Express, utan kan du göra dem i samma kväll eller nästa morgon.
Då kan du ju faktiskt ha saker upp till 20 kilo.
Nästan en gummiplatta.
Så det har varit svårt att, ja jag förstår.
Men en sådan här hubb, hur funkar liksom?
Jag älskar ju logistik och jag ber om ursäkt till alla som skiter detta, men jag tycker detta är kul.
Vart fan, vart gömmer ni dem lokalerna?
Är de i centrala Stockholm till exempel?
Och så är de under marken där i något gammalt cykelgarage eller sånt där?
Eller vart står de här lokalerna och hur stora är de och hela det där?
Precis så.
Det är ofta källa lokaler som du aldrig skulle ha någon aning om när du går förbi att det är ett expresslager.
Det är outnyttjade utrymmen mitt i storstäderna, så exempelvis ett av dem, eller vi har den i Stockholm på Högtorget, som är mitt i smeten.
Där har vi lastkaj och så vidare, men det är hiss ner och så har du nära 1000 kvadratar för tillfället.
Okej, det är ändå ganska stort för att vara mitt inne i en centrala.
Man får ju upp ganska mycket småvaror på en sådan liten.
Jag trodde att det var typ 300-400 kvadrat som ni hade i olika ställen.
Kan du inte känna en viss trötthet över att gå från logistik och teknik till logistik och teknik med den enda stora skillnaden att nu ska du hantera en jävla massa olika e-handlare som har en massa olika åsikter och tankar och tycker att de är viktigast i världen.
Är du inte lite trött på alla de här små mini-cheisarna?
Nej men det skulle jag inte säga.
Du får säga det, alla fattar det.
Det är lugnt.
Nej men jag vet inte, jag valde ju att göra det just för det var ett år där jag satt och funderade mycket på vad jag vill göra med livet.
Det här är något jag verkligen brinner för.
Det kanske låter konstigt för alla som lyssnar men jag står i duschen och tänker på logistik, robotar, automation och hur man ska optimera det här.
De här typ av kedjorna.
Så för mig är det bara roligt.
Jag menar inte på ett drygt sätt men går det att lösa i Sverige?
Är inte folk lite för okej med långa leveranstider?
Är vi inte lite för glesby?
Absolut centrala Stockholm men alla vi andra bor inte där.
Det är bara alla som gör eventen som bor där.
Alla andra bor nån annanstans.
Jag vet inte, vårt stora hypotes är att det här har skett i andra delar av världen och det kommer komma till Europa och det börjar redan ske.
Som e-handlare måste du alltid ställa dig frågorna till hur du står gentemot konkurrensen.
Det finns dels e-handlare eller kedjor som har fysiska butiker, h&m, apoteken och sådär, som faktiskt kan ringa, valt få dåra, bring, mubar bike alla som kör, cykeleveranser och fråga, kan ni komma och hämta upp en order och leverera den på någon timme till vår kund?
Och det sker ju, det är en del apotek som gör så bland annat.
Och sen har vi Amazon som börjar sprida ut sig i Europa och nu till och med i Sverige med sitt Amazon primary-bjudande där de kan leverera samma dag eller nästa.
Och om du som e-handlare ska konkurrera med dem, då blir det väldigt tufft om du har två till fem dagar till ett ombud.
Det varieras ju jättemycket mellan kategori till kategori.
Men det blir tufft redan som det är nu och det kommer bli snabbare och snabbare.
För allt datatyder på att allt annat lika så är en snabbare lärarnas bättre.
Så om vi säljer samma saker till samma pris och ena levererar på tre dagar och den andra på tre timmar, så kommer man välja den som är snabbare.
Så det här är en stor förändring i sektorn som sker.
Det börjar hända i Europa och det kommer snart vara normalt med samhälle nästa dagar leveranser även i Sverige.
Vad är vinningen i pengar eller liknande?
Ni har ju större logistikcenter då.
Och så har ni de här hubbarna.
Och då gissar jag att de är, jag kallar det hubbar nu, ni har säkert något bra namn på det.
Men då gissar jag att det är en högre kostnad att ligga i den.
Det känns liksom rimligt.
Men då gissar jag att e-handlarna räknar på det och ser att de tjänar pengar på att nyttja den här tjänsten, annars hade ni väl inte haft den.
Vad är det man tjänar?
Hur stor är vinsten för e-handlarna?
Jag förstår att det är olika men vad kan ni se?
Vad säljer ni in för siffror?
Hur motiverar man den här tjänsten i reda pengar?
Det är ett typiskt sätt att man tänker så att det här måste vara mycket dyrare.
Men så är det inte riktigt fallet.
Utan det är dyrare om du ska ha express-leverans, alltså en timme, eller en, två timmar.
Då blir själva läsmildelen dyrare.
Så då betalar du lite mer i frakt.
Men resten är inte dyrare och om det nöjer dig med att exempelvis ha inom sex timmar samma kväll eller nästa morgon, då kan det till och med i vissa fall vara billigare, eller runt samma pris.
Och en stor del av det hela är att vi gör så gott vi kan för att förespå framtiden och placera gods så nära konsument som möjligt.
Så det vi gör är att vi förlänger den del i kedjan som bulkshippas.
Så att vi kör i bulk in till stan och därefter en så pass kort distans att varan kan hålla sig inom stan och därmed så kan du få både bra effektivitet i form av många stopp men också så är det väldigt kort distans.
Så det gör att priset drar faktiskt inte iväg och så kör du leveranser som exempelvis samma kväll.
Då har du motsvarande priser som om du skulle köra någon liknande hem till dörren leverans på kvällen utifrån centrallaget.
Är det ni som då hanterar den då?
Jag hade den frågan där i början men kan jag liksom lämna fritt spelrum till er och säga att kan ni se att de här varorna går oftare så det hade varit mer logiskt att ställa in dem i hubben eller eller sköter e-handlaren det?
Vem tar besluten?
Både och, jag skulle säga att vi stöttar mycket i processen.
Vi tittar på data, vi hjälper att välja ut de bästa produkterna.
Samtidigt så finns det ibland vissa strategiska saker som gör att e-handlaren vill välja vissa andra produkter som exempelvis ett visst varumärke som man vill promota eller om man då ska göra en kampanj och en viss grej och då väljer man såklart det.
Men är det inte någon speciell händelse då brukar vi titta på data och rekommendera vilka typer av produkter som ska vara i hubbarna.
När du jobbade på Vemla så sa du att du jobbade rätt intensivt och sen fick du ta en liten paus där och sånt där.
Nu när du gick in i Briso, du hade ju ändå tänkt mycket på såhär vill jag göra eller sånt här och absolut att du gillar det här området.
Men vad var det som var, vad var det du tänkte nu ska göra det här annorlunda?
Vad gör du den här gången som gör att du känner dig trygg och lugn i att nu har du valt rätt väg i livet?
Ja frågan är om man någonsin vet det.
Men det är en hel del av saker gjort annorlunda.
Framför allt så lärde jag mig av vikten av att ha rätt team, samma vision och inne på samma villkor.
Och vi är finansierade av extern kapital, vilket Vemble också var.
Och även här vikten av att ha med sig rätt människor som faktiskt kan bidra på resan.
Så vi har fått otroligt mycket hjälp.
Sen skulle jag säga att det stora är nog att vi har ett väldigt starkt team som brinner för det vi gör och vi får jättemycket hjälp i det nätverk vi har av investerare som gör att det blir mycket roligare och mycket enklare.
Inte lika mycket problem som om man drar åt olika håll.
Men vi alla brinner för det.
Jag tror det är en förutsättning för att det ska bli bra.
Är det det som är the key take away?
Att ni ska ha samma slutvision?
Eller finns det olika personlighetsdrag du går på eller har funderat på?
Måste du kunna ta en öl med dem och tycka att det här var chill?
Vad är inte viktigt och vad är viktigt i personligheterna?
Absolut kemi.
Det är klart att man ska kunna hänga med varandra och undgås och tycka att det är kul.
Däremot så tror jag inte att man behöver vara speciellt lika med varandra.
Det är något bra tvärtom om man har olika personligheter.
Det jag alltid kommer tillbaka till och tycker mig att upptäcka med ORND är att det gäller att man har samma värderingar.
Det är grundvärderingarna, att man tror på samma sak.
Därefter så är det nästan bara bra om man skiljer sig i övrigt.
Så att det är kompetens och hur man är som person och så vidare.
När du säger grundvärderingar, är det typ att man är schysst?
Att man anstränger sig?
Är det sådana grundvärderingar eller är det att logistik är det viktigaste som finns i världen?
På vilken metanivå pratar vi om värderingar?
Jag tror absolut att man bör ha intresset att tycka om logistik och så vidare, men det är väl inte det jag tänker på, utan det är snarare en syn på saker.
Vad vill vi åstadkomma?
Ska man jobba mycket?
Ska man jobba lite?
Pratar man med varandra på helger eller är det helgerna helga?
Ja men ger man rätt för sig absolut ärlighet och så vidare, sådana här typ av grundvärderingar.
Säger ni det när ni säger upp någon typ att jag är ledsen, du är bara inte en skön människa.
Du är jättekompetent men sorry.
Hur märker man att någon, har du någon i gruppen som är jävligt olik dig som person men ändå har samma värderingar?
Kan du beskriva dens personlighetsdrag i så fall?
Jag har aldrig riktigt hamnat i den positionen att jag ser upp någon av den anledningen.
Jag vet inte om jag är den bästa att ge tipsen om rekrytering och hur man ser sådant.
Absolut, vi är ett gäng och väldigt olika livssituationer, vi lever våra liv på väldigt olika sätt men har ändå alltid respekterat varandra, har på många sätt liknande värderingar, exempelvis vi alla jobbar hårt, för oss är det okej att ringa varandra på helgerna.
Det är inget konstigt, snarare är det något man gör till och från när det behövs.
Allt av att ärliga, jag tror att det är en väldigt stor grej som kan göra det tufft att snabbt lätta på trycket om det är någonting, och ta det upp front istället för att hålla inne på det.
Så många typer av sådana värderingar att vi är beredda om hur vi ska driva det här för att få det att funka.
Jag köper det, jag tror att det är jätteviktigt.
Vill du berätta lite om er expansion?
Och kanske också vilket du tycker är roligast, är det den stora lagerlogistiken?
För visst har den öppnats morgongåva, är inte det mäckat för alla i någon logistik nu efter rapportera?
Eller är det de här små grejerna som ska ut i alla stora städer?
Vad går du igång på och hur ser framtiden ut?
Jag tycker båda har sin charm.
Jag vet inte om jag gillar den ena mer än den andra, men visionen är absolut att öppna fler mikrohubbar och växa geografiskt i fler städer.
Det är väl det jag skulle säga som saknas i Europa och där vi verkligen kan fylla en lucka.
Men är ni bara i Sverige idag?
Idag har vi lager bara i Sverige.
Vi skickar ju med centrallagret över hela världen, men just nu bara svensk presence.
Vad är nästa marknad?
Du måste vara nedåt, det kan inte vara åt sidorna.
Ja men precis, vi tittar mycket nedåt.
Ni får inte avslöja något.
Jag slutar frågan där.
Vill du, en gång så hade jag med Helene Rothstein i podden och då sa hon att om man ska göra riktigt bra intervjuer så ska man alltid gräva där folk inte vill prata.
För då blir det mest intressant.
Men jag känner att jag inte är journalist så jag bara slutar.
En annan fråga som jag undrar mycket om är hela den här kapitalresningen.
För att jag känner på något sätt att vi är motpoler i kanske hur vi tänker på sådana grejer.
Jag gillar att se gymkompagniet som en långsamt växande slimeboll.
Som växer med 1% per år och så håller den på under 45 år.
Och om jag dör så är jag ganska nöjd med att den blev som en stor slimeboll.
Men jag tänker att du drivs av den här här är en ny marknad, nu ska vi komma in i detta.
Vi har hittat ett område som inte folk har kommit in i och så vill jag etablera det och så vill jag bli störst på den nischen.
Jag tänker att det är ett visst mindset som jag till viss del saknar.
Kan du berätta hur du ser på att använda, be folk om pengar för att investera i din dröm eller i er affärsidé.
Jag tycker det är en intressant, när man verkligen tror på någonting och så ska man in i det snabbt.
Hur man får med folk på den resan eller den visionen.
Hur jobbar man där?
Känns inte det lite skumt att folk ska ja men fan, jag hoppar på din dröm istället.
Jag förstår vad du säger och jag tror att varken det ena eller andra är fel och det är nog väldigt mycket mellan varför typ av case och situation är.
Det finns definitivt anledningar till att inte ta in kapital och driva det som du har gjort och på sätt och vis och kanske det är mindre huvudvärk när man gör det så.
Men det finns massa fördelar och speciellt i vårt case, tittar man på logistik så det är en typisk volymbusiness.
Ju mer volym du har desto bättre är det.
Om det är till och med så du når lönsamhet, du behöver ha volym.
Det gör det därför logiskt att försöka växa till sig så snabbt som möjligt så att man blir lönsam.
Sen så är av i den här visionen om att det här kommer komma till Europa, så vi tittar inte bara på Sverige.
Vilket gör att det kommer kosta om man ska röra sig ut i hela världen.
Sen så är det en väldigt tydlig fördel som många ofta glömmer när man har den här diskussionen.
Jag vet inte riktigt om folk bara köper in på min vision, utan de som har kommit in i casen tror själva på den här visionen och vill se den bli verklig.
Och det är fantastiskt att få med sig många kloka människor som har gjort framgångsrika resor och få deras hjälp.
Det är något som jag tror många underskattar, hur stor skillnad det kan göra.
I vårt fall så säkert 80% av allt bra som har hänt har kommit för att våra investerare på något sätt eller de som är inbannade har hjälpt oss.
Så det finns alltid för-
och nackdelar, men just i vårt case så tycker jag det är logiskt att ta in kapital och snabbt växa till sig.
Vilka nivåer behöver man nå inom en sån här business för att det ska börja vara, inte lönsamt, utan för att det ska börja vara rimliga nivåer för att börja förhandla.
För jag tycker ofta att folk tänker på det som att ja ni ska bli stora och så, ja ni är omsatt över 200 miljoner.
Det är inte jättemycket för logistik.
Alltså det är ju inte en jätte business.
Eller ja de växte jättemycket här under fem år, absolut men ska man bli en logistikhjärte, kanske ska man växa under 30 år och etablera sig i hela.
Så jag bara funderar på hur stor är den här visionen?
När är ni i ditt huvud liksom en etablerad aktör?
Hur stort måste det vara då?
Jag vet inte om jag har svarat på den, eller definitionen på den frågan.
Vårt mål är att röra sig till Europa.
Och det är det vi jobbar mot.
Jag tror att innan vi har nått dit så skulle jag inte säga att vi är en etablerad aktör.
I alla fall inte mitt i huvudet.
Vi har tagit en position i Sverige.
Vi gör det väldigt bra.
Vårt mål är att sätta upp fler hubbar i Europa.
Menar ni typ Frankrike, Tyskland, Spanien eller räknar man in Portugal och Irlando?
Det är väl inte Portugal och Irlando vi tittar på först.
Vi kanske kommer, men vi tittar på större marknader.
Speciellt för express-leveranser så är det större städer som är lämpade initialt i alla fall.
Jag är lite fascinerad över, nu gillar jag det som, jag gillar att ni kör combo-grejen för jag alltid är fascinerad när folk bygger sådana här snabbleveranser i städer.
På något sätt har de ett halvt erbjudande eftersom man bara erbjuder de städerna och då måste man ändå lösa logistik runtomkring de städerna.
Man kan inte jobba med en aktör, man måste jobba med tusen olika aktörer.
Och är man en liten e-handlare eller en stor, så finns det en massa problem i det.
Så jag gillar den här kombon som ni kör där.
Är det e-handlare som har åsikter om vilka städer och vilka länder och sånt där?
Eller är det ni som har satt tankarna på att ni ska?
Nej men vi pratar med våra kunder och e-handlarna.
Det som är fint är att vi gör helheten med både centrallagret och hubbarna.
Vi har ju en del volym utomlands redan.
Nu när vi tittar på våra expansionsplaner så pratar vi med våra kunder och ser så här, men vad finns det redan volym?
Var kan vi på ett lönsamt och effektivt sätt expandera?
Där vi redan från dag ett har en viss volym som får lagret att gå runt.
I en special så fick vi börja utan volym och det är väldigt tufft.
Nu har vi möjligheten att faktiskt gå in i städer på ett mycket mer hållbart sätt.
Delvis är det strategiskt, där vi tittar på vilka länder och städer är logiska för den här typen av tjänst.
Men sen tittar vi också på vad kan vi göra det effektivt och vad har vi redan volym?
Du pratar väldigt gott om investerarna här.
Vad är det, om ni kollar på framtida investerare, för ni kommer väl ta in massa ner i kapital?
Vad är det ni letar efter?
Är det olika gamla nissar från gamla fraktbolag?
Eller är det folk som kan teknik?
Eller är det folk med kontakter?
Vad är era guldtyper?
Vad är det ni letar efter?
Jag skulle säga allt det du sa.
Tittar man på vad de har idag redan så är det många inom e-handel.
Men även sälj, logistik, kapitalanskaffning, många som har skalat upp verksamheter både i Sverige och utomlands.
Så kriterier är det väl inte, men vi vill ha med oss folk som kan bidra på något sätt.
Och det måste inte vara ett eller annat, men vi försöker komplettera framförallt med det vi inte redan har.
Men sen så har vi vissa kärnan områden som såklart är e-handel, logistik, teknik och mjukvara.
Kan du ibland bara, jag tycker om, det kan du inte svara på, men jag tänkte säga, tycker du om alla investerarna?
Finns det vissa du bara känner?
Sluta ringa mig nu, det är någonsin inte spelar ingen roll här.
Du kanske inte kan svara på den.
Nej, det är något enkelt, jag har inte riktigt, vart Peter, med vilka som har tagit in det där bolaget och tycker att, som sagt, vissa är mer eller mindre aktiva, men alla har någon typ av funktion och värde.
Fan, vad du är politiskt korrekt i dina svar väldigt.
Jag känner att vi tillhör två olika motpolen här.
Det är därför jag aldrig kan ha investerare, jag hade sagt något dumt direkt.
Hur gör man när man, för jag gissar, nu du får rätta mig här givetvis, men jag gissar att detta är ett case som kommer ta in ganska mycket pengar under ganska lång tid, så länge man ser en logisk tillväxt och så där.
Hur gör man för att du och dina medgrundare och de tidiga investerarna inte bara långsamt, successivt takta neråt och blir små aktörer utan makt?
Svår fråga, utan makt, det är klart att det växer om man späs ut.
De allra flesta försvarar sin andel och behåller sin andel, så det är väl inget som riktigt, ska man säga, därut på det sättet.
Men det är klart att vi växer, vi spas ut, men samtidigt så ökar också värderingen i bolaget och blir större och större.
Så även om det är ett problem.
Kan du tycka att det känns konstigt att lämna ifrån dig, för det är väl ni som, hur många var ni som grundade?
Det var väl initialt jag.
Aha, du var ensam i starten.
Ja men exakt, jag var ensam.
Jag hade framförallt en investerare, Omit Ganberg, som jag träffade på Vembla-tiden.
När jag lämnade ringde hon och sa att jag har lämnat, jag vet inte vad jag ska göra.
Han var väl såhär, jag vill vara med på din nästa grej, låt oss hålla kontakt och det gjorde vi.
Vi ballade den här idén mycket och han var då den första investeraren egentligen, på sätt och vis den som gjorde det möjligt för oss att ens komma igång.
Annars var jag initialt ensam men tog snabbt in folk.
Bland annat Ara som började på sälj men sen också sköter support och customer success, som egentligen är den som har gjort att vi kan växa såhär.
Så vi blev ett gäng ganska fort, initialt var det jag.
Finns det några misstag du har gjort när du har tagit in investerare tidigare som du kan ge råd till folk att bara gör inte det här?
Ja, absolut.
Jag tror det är viktigt att du har folk som faktiskt kan hjälpa dig.
Alltså strategiskt bra investerare.
Det måste inte alltid vara så.
Men du går misstånd väldigt mycket om du inte gör det.
Och sen så tror jag att det måste passa din vision och vart du är på väg.
Så det går inte, om du ska starta ett företag där du räknar ut att du kommer att ta in flera hundra miljoner kronor, då blir det inte så bra om du tar in någon som kan stoppa in hundratusen initialt och sen inte hjälpa dig att följa upp.
Du måste tänka på såhär, om jag ska ta in så mycket pengar, hur ska jag kunna få in dem?
Kommer de som är med idag kunna stötta mig framåt?
Och det måste inte alltid vara så, men om du inte har sådana personer, då måste du fundera på hur kommer jag att lösa det sen?
För du nämner det här om vision flera gånger, så gissningsvis är det rätt viktig punkt.
Men hur hård ska man då vara i den dialogen?
För ofta kommer man i lite och man kanske behöver pengar, så då är man lite beredd att inte säga, inte så att man ljuger, men att man följer med lite i investerarens dialog.
Så att säga, ja det kan vi titta på, eller ja det kanske är aktuellt.
Hur hård måste man vara?
Ska man vara så jävla hård i?
Nej, fan, nej, såhär ser planen ut.
Var med eller var inte med?
Nej men jag tror att det är ett valet misstag att vika sig.
Jag tror att skillnad på vision och plan, planen kommer definitivt att ändras.
Så där så absolut ska man vika sig eller hitta andra idéer och väga framåt.
Men jag tror det är ett misstag att ta in folk som inte är med på samma vision.
För det är då de också börjar skava.
Utan tvärtom, just på den pucken så skulle jag nog, verkligen vara noga med att ta in rätt folk som vill följa med på just den resan.
Och som jag nämnde, det är inte när det är så att folk köper in i din vision, utan det bästa är om de själva har samma vision.
Och tillsammans köper in på det.
Ja fan, jag är sjukt tacksam att vi fick låna er din tid här, Dino.
Fan vad smart du låter.
Jag känner mig, med vissa som jag intervjuar så känner jag mig som en liten lantis, och här känner jag mig lite som en lantis, och det är lite gött.
Stort tack för att du var med i podden i alla fall.
Tack så jättemycket, Johan.
Du har varit med på den här listan Forbes 30 under 30, och när jag var under 30 så pillade jag fortfarande en avelludd.
Hur var det att vara ambitiös som ung?